münchen hat auch im winter eine ziemlich
freundliche und einladende stuck und die
gelegenheit marienplatz frauen 44 und
münchner lebensart kennen zu lernen
solltet ihr euch nicht entgehen lassen
und wenn es geschneit hat findet ihr
sogar gelegenheiten für wintersport im
englischen daten etwa könnt ihr wurde
oder fc teisbach surfern gleichtun
der winter eignet sich natürlich auch
für museumsbesuche die wichtigsten
häuser findet ihr alle im museum
vierteln dem so genannten grund areal in
der alten pinakothek ender könnt ihr in
die europäische kunstgeschichte
einkaufen
schon die beiden könige auf dem haus
mittelbach haben gerne gesammelt alles
was rang und namen hat von albrecht
dürer ist peter paul rubens
die alte pinakothek spieler in der
wirklichen oberliga net gehört für den
berühmtesten galerien der welt eben dank
der sammelleidenschaft der früheren
generation der wittelsbacher
[Musik]
das kontrastprogramm findet ihr gleich
nebenan im museum brandhorst einige
werke von andy warhol zeugnis in der
sammlung des ehepaares brandhorst geht
es vor allem um die kunst zwanzigsten
jahrhundert
[Musik]
von daher ist es natürlich ganz ganz
toller punkt weil man einfach menschen
die mit gegenwartskunst nicht so viel zu
tun hat auch ein super einstieg geben
kann jeder kennt warhol
aber man kann hat eben auch die
möglichkeit zu vertiefen und dann in
andere sphären mal zu leiten und auf dem
rücken verweisen
und wenn ihr nach dem museumsbesuch eine
stärkung braucht dann für das
hofbräuhaus eine münchner institution
weit über 425 jahren reiseführer sagt
das muss man gesehen haben
toll dass alle du getroffen auch wenn es
beim die besucher ansturm vielleicht gar
nicht so aussieht findet ihr meist noch
einen platz im hofbräuhaus von 1300
gäste bewirtet werden
[Musik]